uh you might remember that back in 2017
hurricane maria
ravaged puerto rico the island of
american citizens that is southeast of
florida
we learned at the time that many
republicans
didn't know that puerto ricans are
american citizens we also
knew at the time that donald trump
didn't really seem to care very much
about it the administration was slow
to send the aid that they did send and
we know that when donald trump went he
didn't really seem to
be taking it super seriously remember
when he showed up and tossed paper
towels into the crowd
like he was shooting hoops we're playing
that video now
for our television and online video
audience but
now we have to think it wasn't merely
indifference to puerto rico from the
trump administration in 2017 and 2018
that it was actually much worse
because of a new report from the
department of hud
housing and urban development the
inspector general
of the department of hud has issued a
report
that says that because of tension
between department of hud
and the office of management and budget
under trump
all sorts of bogus procedural hurdles
were put in place to delay
puerto rico actually getting the money
now some of you will listen to me say
this and you'll go up and you'll look at
money approved for puerto rico and you
will say hold hold hold on a second
david
the money was approved 20 billion was
approved for puerto rico
and trump announced it and talked about
it and of course
yes the money was approved but the whole
point is
approving funds doesn't disperse the
funds they are separately processed
and the office of management and budget
which would approve the distribution of
the funds
around that time started to require hud
to send grant notices for disaster funds
through an interagency review process
for approval
which never before had been required
which dramatically slowed everything
down
investigators found that omb never
required such a review
for recovery funds before and it was a
requirement created in this
particular situation former hud
secretary ben
carson would be a perfect guy to ask
about all of this
he declined to be interviewed by
investigators
access to hud information was the later
denied multiple times throughout the
course of the investigation
and the trump administration's omb also
insisted
on completely overhauling puerto rico's
property management records
suspension of its minimum wage on
federal contracts and a whole other
other bunch of prerequisites imagine
saying we're approving 20 billion for
you
but to get it you have to remove the
minimum wage provision
on federal contracts what
and some hud officials realistically and
and rightly worried
that the requirements were number one
uh uh designed to make it impossible
for the money to actually be distributed
and even potentially beyond hud's
ability
to actually do two top hut officials
admitted knowing that they
were on purpose missing the deadline to
issue a notice that would unlock
billions in federal recovery funds to
puerto rico
they're not even denying it or i mean
they didn't at the time
ben carson later defended his agency's
actions by saying
trump's talking points which are oh
there were we wanted to prevent
corruption and irregularities that's why
we needed to do this stuff then ben
carson refused to actually be
interviewed by investigators here
so now that we have a bigger picture not
only did the trump administration
allegedly block the much-needed aid from
getting to puerto rico
they also obstructed an investigation
looking into why puerto rico didn't
ultimately get the money
and there's nothing surprising here
whatsoever last week
or the week before it's hard to keep
track of all the scandals we were
talking about
another newly uncovered trump
administration scam and i said
it's not clear we will ever know the
full scope of the grift
or the scamming that this administration
did
every time we do learn about something
new like this
my reaction is of course they did that
if you look at the public disdain that
trump had
for puerto rico and you look at the
public indifference that trump exhibited
none of these revelations is remotely
surprising
or hard to believe and then of course i
mean you know we
we can't really come full circle on the
implications of this
without mentioning that no matter what
comes to light
a huge portion of the 75 million people
who voted for donald trump in 2020 would
take him right back for another four
years
they would gleefully vote him back in if
he runs in 2024
and as we will talk about a little bit
later on in the program uh the vast
majority of them
still believe that joe biden did not
legitimately win
the 2020 election but there is no news
story
there is no grift or scam or revelation
that would change their minds and that's
a major problem for the country
these revelations show the complicit
nature
not complicit the the the responsibility
of the trump administration in puerto
rico being a disaster for as long as it
was after the hurricane
uh but as much of a problem as that is
we also
have a an ongoing problem in that
the vast majority of the 75 million
people that voted for the guy would vote
for him again and we're going to talk
about that poll a little bit later today